at the end of the day life is about
being happy kim kardashian filed for
divorce from
kanye west in february after six years
of marriage
now a source is telling e.t she's
relieved happy to see that chapter close
and ready to put this hardship behind
her but the source adds
she's worried about her ex kim is
concerned about kanye's stability but
she has
full faith that he will strive to do his
best to be the father and person he once
was
i always know his heart the source adds
that kim will
always have love for kanye as the father
of their four children
but romantically she's done as for the
rapper
our source says kanye has hope that they
will reconcile but he is not expecting
that in the immediate future
i've seen him go through a lot and he's
just the most
genuine person the source explains that
the divorce has been difficult for kanye
but knowing he has access to their
little ones and has split custody is
making the transition
easier as for the kids seven-year-old
north
five-year-old saint three-year-old
chicago and one-year-old psalm
e.t source says they are doing great
adding that kim and her family have done
an excellent job at coaching the kids
through it quote
kim has had her moments of feeling
overwhelmed as a mom of course
but the fact that her family has been so
unified and supported her through this
difficult time
has made things so much easier for her
to process
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
the source adds that kim has been
spending a lot of time with her family
members
and they have been a huge support system
for her
and kim she's making a point of staying
busy
quote she is not interested in dating
right now and is focused on
her family and healing the situation